[Music]
when we talk about our opioid problem
it's important to understand that what
we're dealing with is an epidemic of
opioid addiction meaning a sharp
increase in the number of Americans
suffering from the condition of opioid
addiction there are two age groups that
have been affected we have a younger
group in an older group the younger
group of people who become opioid
addicted or mostly people in their 20s
and 30s who have developed opioid
addiction either from taking opioid pain
medicine for recreational purposes
abusing the drug to experience the
effect or taking an opioid pain medicine
as prescribed by a doctor or they
developed addiction a little bit from
both ways there might be a medical
exposure for wisdom teeth sports injury
the young person likes the affect uses
recreationally for some period of time
and then becomes addicted regardless of
how the young person develops their
addiction to opioids once addicted they
need to maintain their opioid supply and
they have a very hard time doing that
visiting doctors and dentists doctors
don't like giving healthy looking 25
year olds a large quantity of opioid
pain medicine on a monthly basis that
really makes a doctor uncomfortable so
young people who are becoming opioid
addicted very quickly wind up on the
black market in order to maintain their
opioid supply and what we know is that
on the black market prescription opioids
are very expensive young people who need
to maintain their opioid supply have
been switching to heroin because it's
more cost effective $10 bag of heroin
will do what a $30 pill would do and
what we've seen happen over the past 20
years is that young people in regions of
the country where heroin is available
have switched and heroin has moved into
more regions of the country where it
wasn't previously available to meet the
demand for it by these young people who
have become opioid addicted and now need
to maintain their opioid supply there's
also an older group of Americans who
have become opioid addicted over the
past 20 years these are people in their
40s 50 60 70s and 80s this older group
is mostly developing opioid addiction
through medical use of of opioids very
often the opioids start off as a
prescription for an acute pain problem
the patient stays on the opioid and then
becomes a chronic pain patient on
long-term opioids this older group when
they become addicted they don't
generally have a hard time finding
doctors who will prescribe them a large
quantity of pills on a monthly basis and
even when the patient's own primary care
doctor may begin to get uncomfortable
the doctor doesn't want to put that
label that that stigmatized label on on
their patients and the patient will
often explain the aberrant drug taking
behavior as being caused by a worsening
of their pain the patient is saying I
took extra pills because my pain was
worse and what we see very often is that
the primary care doctors are referring
these patients to pain specialists
rather than for addiction treatment and
something that's not very well known is
that when we compare the overdose death
rate in that older group that can obtain
pills more easily from doctors to the
overdose death rate in the younger group
that's been switching terilyn we
actually see significant
more overdose deaths in that older group
even with this very dangerous heroin
that's available today that that's
especially dangerous because of fentanyl
that's being mixed into it despite that
very dangerous heroin supply we still
see more overdose deaths from
prescription opioids